[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم موقف ايران بما
يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بالغ
الاهميه لان ايران طرف رئيسي في هذا
الصراع سواء ظل محدودا في غزه او اتسع
مداه بطبيعه الحال ومن المهم جدا ان نعرف
كيف يفكر الايرانيون وماذا يقولون في
صحفهم من اجل هذه المهمه انا بستيف صديقي
اليوم الدكتور محمد محسن ابو النور رئيس
المنتدى الع العربي لتحليل السياسات
الايرانيه والمتخصص في الشان الايراني
علشان يطلعنا على ما يجري في وسائل
الاعلام الايرانيه ومراكز البحث الايرانيه
مساء الخير معنا الدكتور اهلا وسهلا اهلا
وسهلا يا رب تكون باتم صحه وسلامه ربنا
يخليك الحمد لله كله تمام يا ترى
الايرانيين بصفه عامه مشغولين بالصراع
الدائر في غزه زي ما العالم العربي مشغول
ليلا ونهارا ولا عندهم اهتمامات متعدده
يعني على مستوى الدوله ولا على مستوى
النخب ولا على مستوى الشعب قول لنا على
مستوى الاول على مستوى الدوله اه على
مستوى الدوله طبعا في الدوله مشغوله في
ملفات كتيره جدا معقده بالنسبه لايران امن
قومي الوضع في ارمينيا شبه منفجر في
ناجورنو كارباخ وحتى الان الازمه لم تنتهي
الوضع في افغانستان على الحدود الايرانيه
الافغانيه مساله حياء اوموت بالنسبه
لايران لان طلبان طبعا زي ما حضرتك عارف
مسيطره على جزء كبير من حصه ايران المائيه
في نهر هلمند وده اهم نهر بيرفض لايران
الوضع حوالين ايران غير اه اه غير غير جيد
تماما الاراضي الفلسطينيه بعيده جغرافيا
عن ايران فبالتالي البعد الجغرافي بيدي
بيرجع القضيه لاولويات فيما ميتعلق بالامن
القومي لاولويات يعني ادنى مستوى من
التحديات الكبيره اللي حوالين ايران
بالفعل واللي هم حتى الايرانيين في وسائل
الاعلام ومراكز الفكر بيقولوا ان الغرب هو
اللي شغلنا في هذه ال الازمات مثلا وعشان
ندلل على وجهه نظرهم امريكا ايام ازمه
ناجورنو كارباخ اللي هي كانت الشهر اللي
قبل اللي فات كانت عامله مناورات مع
ارمينيا في ظل ان كان في هجوم من اذربيجان
على القوات الارمينيه في المنطقه كان في
مناورات امريكيه مع ارمينيا في ارمينيا
فبالتالي هم عارفين ان امريكا محاصرا او
بتحاول تحاصرهم في ملفات مختلفه وبيتهم
طلبان في الاعلام ان هو ممول امريكيا فده
اللي مخلي جماعه طالبان حتى يعني تشغل
ايران وتؤثر عليها تستنزفها يعني اه ف
الوضع منفجر حوالين ايران في الامور اللي
بتنص الامن القومي الايراني اللحظي الفوري
ما يعني انه الاراضي المحتله على حد اقصى
هي واحد من قضايا متعدده بتضغط على صنع
القرار الايراني نعم لكن ليست تهديدا حق
حقيقيا فعليا فايران ملخص الوضع ايران
منشغله جدا عندها ازمات داخليه وخارجيه
كبيره جدا الاضيه الفلسطينيه بالنسبه لمصر
مثلا قضيه امن قومي رقم واحد بالنسبه لنا
دي الاردن والب وما الى ذلك فبالنسبه
لايران هي قضيه سياسيه قضيه لها ابعاد
دعائيه وطبعا انا لا اقلل من ان ايران
مهتمه فعلا بفلسطين ووسائل الاعلام
بالكامل لا تجد صحيفه او مركز بحثي في
الصفحه الاولى مافيش خبر او مقال عن
فلسطين ده لا جداله في ذلك حتى المنشتات
الرئيسيه وهنقول ده بالتفصيل دلوقتي فعلى
مستوى الدوله طبعا مهتمين بفلسطين لكن
الاولويه مش رقم مش مش رقم واحد قض على
مستوى النخب طبعا القضيه الفلسطينيه رقم
سبعه او مانيه مثلا بعد قضايا كتير جدا
النخب الموجوده في ايران وهي مش كلها
دينيه في نخب قوميين وفي نخب وفي يسار حتى
الان وفي يمين في كل الاطراف الاطياف
السياسيه طلاب الجامعات غير مشغولين
بالموضوع اصلا يعني حضرتك لو فتحت
الفيسبوك مثلا او التيليجرام اللي هم
بيستخدموه باستمرار ا عند اي مصري او اي
عربي هتلاقي باستمرار لازم كل يوم بوست او
كل اسبوع بوست عن غزه وفلسطين لا في
الجانب الايراني هذا الكلام مش موجود
فبالتالي لو قسمنا بقى ايران ثلاث اطياف
الدوله مهتمه طبعا بقضايا فلسطينيه
وموجوده في كل الكلام وفي كل وسائل
الاعلام وفي كل مراكز الفكر بس ليست هي
الاولويه الاولى لان ايران عندها تحديات
كتير على مستوى النخب طبعا ض فلسطين
مهتمين بيه وبيتكلموا عنها باستمرار لكن
ايضا ليس على المست ليست اولويه اولى
اطياف كثير من المجتمع الايراني غير
المؤيدين للنظام بالنسبه لهم قضيه فلسطين
اصلا قضيه ليست ذات اهميه بل بالعكس ان هم
عايزين يحلوا المشكله واسرائيل تبقى عايشه
في سلام معانا وما ده تعبير دقيق يعني اذا
هناك اطياف من القوى اللي هي معارضه
للنظام تتمنى انه او ما عندهاش مشكله مع
اسرائيل لكن القوى اللي هنا صفه بالمحافظه
او المؤيده للنظام او الداعمه ليه اكيد
هيكون عندها مشكله مع اسرائيل مضبوط مش
كدهه برده مزبوط طيب انا هسالك سؤال جانبي
وبعدين اسالك على التفاصيل انت بتقول هي
بالنسبه للنخب مش هي الاولويه الاولى في
اولويات اخرى تدينا مثال كده عشان نبقى
هدف الحلقه ان احنا نفهم ايران وما يجري
فيها اولويات اخرى زي ايه مثلا في الوقت
الحاضر هو اول اولويه بالنسبه للنخب في
الظرف الراهي بكلم على على النخب اه اه
النخب النخب اللي هم مثقفين الناشطين في
الجامعات بعض التنظيمات
اولويت الاساسيه الامن القومي الايراني اه
طبعا
لدرجه ان بعض الناس منهم بيتكلموا مثلا عن
ان التحدي بتاع اوكرانيا وروسيا ده تحدي
غير وارد دلوقتي لان احنا او ايران يعني
مش احنا مش احنا كمصر احنا كيران لو انا
بتكلم بلسان حالهم يعني ان ايران دخلت في
هذا الصراع امدت روسيا ب بطائرات مصيره
دخلت في الصراع بشكل او باخر وده اثر على
اهم شيء بينظر لنخب الايرانيه وهو التهدئه
والتسويه مع مع امريكا باي شكل لان
امريكا زي ما احنا بنقول في مصر بالبلدي
كده قفله عليهم اليه والنور بمعنى ايه
مثلا خدمه سويفت تحويل
الاوال مغلقه العقوبات معظم معظم القطاعات
عليها عقوبات باستثناء مثلا ميناء تبهار
اللي هو في الجنوب بعض الحاجات البسيطه
يعني لكن معظم الدوله مقفوله مغلقه يعني
لو حضرتك ايراني وليك مثلا اخ بيشتغل في
كندا فعايز يبعت لك فلوس يساعدك بيها في
التعليم وما الى ذلك مش بيعرف عشان انظمه
التحويل مغلقه الا بقى لو بعت عن طريق
صديق وصديق ده يسافر يعني في تعقيدات
كبيره جدا يعني فبالتالي
الازمات المتعلقه بانفتاحها الغرب
والتهدئه مع امريكا والتسويه والاندماج في
النظام المالي العالمي ده اولويه اوليه
رقم اويه رقم واحد طبعا لان حياتهم
اليوميه بهذا الاسلوب الادويه مثلا
الناقصه معظم
الادويه الكيميائيه الادويه ذات الاهميه
في علاج السرطانات وما الى ذلك واقفه
تماما طبعا مؤخرا بدات تفتح ش نوعا ما بعد
ايران ما عملت اتفاق مع امريكا
وحررت سجناء امريكيين مقابل 22 مليار
دولار زي ما انت عارف عارف الفلوس دي
ياخدوا يجيبوا بيها دواء من كوريا ومن
اليابان ومن العراق وما الى ذلك طبعا في
في تفصيلات كتير جدا يعني لكن النخب اه
ملخص السؤال النخب ا الاولويه بالنسبه لها
هي الانفتاح الغرب التهدئه مع الغرب لان
الغرب من وجهه نظرهم متحكم في العالم
تقريبا الروس والصينيين نوعا ما مش بيسع
فوهم قوي الهنود نفسهم مش بيسع فوهم وحتى
في مقوله مشهوره لرئيس الراحل راف سنجاني
ان الهنود اللي هم اصلا يعني بيوصفوا بان
هم محطه سخريه من من الشعب الايراني هم
اللي بيضحكوا على الايرانيين مش العكس
اديك مثال مثلا بياخدوا منهم النفط
بالمقيد فبيد ايه مكان النفط بيضحكوا
عليهم بمعنى بيخدعو يعني اللي هو
يعني يعني بيخدعو نوعا ما او وات ايفر
يعني فبيا خدوا النفط الايراني بالمقيد
مقابل ايه مقابل منتجات قطنيه فوط
و وملايات سرير وكلام من هذا القبيل فحتى
راسنج ج قبل ما يموت كان في احدى الجلسات
وده اللي كان مزعل الخامنئي منه بالمناسبه
ا ان هم يعني ضحكوا علينا يعني الهنود
اللي احنا مفروض نضحك عليهم هم اللي
بيضحكوا علينا بيدونا بضائع تافهه
وبياخدوا من مننا سلعه استراتيجيه زي
النفط فبالتالي لازم ننفتح على الغرب عشان
نعرف نبيع النفط في السوق الحره اه بالعر
مجزي بالسعر العالمي بسعر العالمي حتى
الصين بتاخد بمناسبه الصين بتشتري باقل 20
دولار من ايران وبالاجبار حتى الان كان
حتى لما وصل لحجه كان بتشتري ب 67 الصين ف
ده الاولويه الاولى بالنسبه للنخب
الايرانيه طيب عظيم في ظل ان هي واحده من
الاولويات اللي هي مش متقدمه لكنها ليست
في ذل الاهتمامات يعني خصوصا ان في ازمه
مشتعله يا ترى انت رصدت ازاي ردود او يعني
اراء الاعلام الايراني والاعلام الايراني
زي ما انا عرفت منك هو الحقيقه اعلام الى
حد كبير بيعكس توجهات السلطه نعم مش كده
برض يعني يا ريت تقول لنا في العجاله
الاول ان الاعلام انا كنت معتقد ان في
تعدد في وسائل الاعلام فانت قلت لي هو
الاعلام الايراني ا اما صحف تابعه للحكومه
مباشره يعني الحكومه بتصرف عليها مباشره
او اعلام تابع للاحزاب الاصلاحيه او
الاصلاحيين الجماعات
الاصلاحيه فقط لا غير والمحافظين ما
عندهمش ولاب الدوله المحافظين بقى هم مع
الدوله اه اللي هو مثلا زي الجمهور اسلامي
هم شراه وقول لحضرتك بالتفاصيل اسماء
الصحف وتوجهاتها ومعانيها وكل حاجه
فبالتالي معظم الاعلام مافيش اعلام ايراني
من اللي احنا بنقراه واللي بيتنشر يقدر
يخرج عن الخط العام للدوله اه طبعا في
شويه معارضه في شويه اختلاف وجهات النظر
حوالين قضايا هامشيه بس مش قضايا رئيسيه
يعني مافيش مافيش حد في ايران مثلا يقدر
يطلع في صحيفه يدافع عن اسرائيل اه ده غير
موجود طبعا اه ا فدي ثوابت من ثوابت
الدوله ده اللي بيظهر في الاعلام وحتى في
مراكز الفكر طبعا عظيم جدا ده في الحاله
دي اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها انا بعتقد ده
هيكون مفيد في نقطه واحده هو ليه اضرار
كتيره ان الاعلام يكون مع الدوله بس يعني
سواء في ايران او في اي دوله اخرى ولكن في
حالتنا ده معناه انه اللي احنا هسمعه منك
دلوقتي من خلال جوله في الاعلام معناها
انه بيعبر عن النخب الحاكمه على الاقل
مظبوط طيب يا ترى ايه اهم ما شغل الاعلام
في الاسبوع الماضي او في الشهر الماضي منذ
اندلاع الحرب اهم مشاغل الاعلام قضيه
فلسطين يعني مافيش صحيفه مافيش لقاء مافيش
مسؤول يطلع يتكلم في اي موضوع في اي وقت
الا لازم يتكلم عن موضوع غزه وفلسطين
واسرائيل والاعداء التاريخي لاسرائيل
وكلام من هذا القبيل وطبعا في مقوله
مشهوره للخميني حتى كتبها في كتاب اسمه
القضيه الفلسطينيه كتاب مشهور قوي بيقول
ايه بيقول الطريق الى القدس يبدا من
العراق اه عشان ا لازم نمر الاول بخط بري
العراق ثم سوريا ثم لبنان ثم القدس مقوله
مشهوره ف ففي اي صحيفه اي منشت لازم يوميا
اي افتتاحيه بالمناسبه 90% او اكترر من
الصحف بتتكلم عن موضوع فلسطين وغزه ورصد
لحظي للتفاصيل وما الى ذلك لدرجه ان مثلا
وبيجيبوا حاجات معلومات بمناسبه بيه
معلومات مهمه ومعلومات انا مش بشوفها في
الاعلام الدولي حتى ولا العربي ا مثلا في
صحيفه كيهان ودي اهم صحيفه تبعه للمرشد
حاليا صحيفه تقريبا شبه الاولى في الصحف
المحافظه التابعه للنظام ا قالت تقرير كده
حلو قوي بتقول ان ان اسرائيل عندما اخفقت
في الاجتياح البري
لغزه لجات الى الاستعانه بمرتزقة
دي معلومه بالنسبه لي ما شفتهاش وماعرفش
اتاكد منها لان موجوده في صحيفه كيهان ان
اسرائيل بدات ترجع الجيش لورا وتجيب
مرتزقه من بره اجانب من اوروبا وما الى
ذلك ومن اسيا
عشان هم اللي يحاربوا في الصفوف الاولى
يعني والله طبعا انا اول مره اسمع هذه
الملحوظه وطبعا ما عنديش قدره تتوثق منها
بس تبدو انها تتسق مع المنطق لانه جيوش
كتيره لما بداوا يستعينوا بفكره اللي هي
المرتزقه او الجيوش الخاصه او شركات ما
يسمى بالامن زي مثلا فاجنر الروسيه او
بلاك وتر الامريكيه كان هدفها نفس الهدف
اللي اكيد اسرائيل عاوزاه انه لو لحقت
خسائر الشعب ما يقولش انه انا او يحاسب
الحكومه على سقوط خسائر في الجيش ملحوظه
صغيره قبل ما اسالك عن اهم ما جا هل كن ان
كل الصحف على مدار شهر زي ما انت بتقول
شغالها الاساسي القضيه الفلسطينيه لا
يتعارض مع ما قلته انه القضيه الفلسطينيه
ليست اولويه ضاغطه على النخب هو فلسطين
بالنسبه ايران قضيه ايديولوجيه يعني طبعا
انت عارف حضرتك الايديولوجيه من روافع
السياسه الخارجيه الايرانيه ا قضيه العداء
مع اسرائيل قضيه الانسجام مع الخط السياسي
لمؤسس الدوله اللي هو الخميني اللي هو
اصلا دخل في صراع عنيف مع الشاه بسبب
التطبيع حضرتك هتعرف ان تطبيع ايران مع
اسرائيل او اعتراف ايران باسرائيل ايران
تقريبا تاني دوله اعترفت باسرائيل في
الدول الاسلاميه بعد التركيه اه اعترفت ب
على مرحلتين اول مرحله سنه 50 ه كده
الدكتور بيتكلم على ايام حكم الشاه يعني
حكم الشاه اه فعشان بس الناس تفهم الجذور
المشكله ايه ايران اعترفت باسرائيل على
مرحلتين مرحله سنه 1950 اه ولما حصل ده
كان في رئيس وزراء اسمه محمد مصدق وكان
بيعوني دي مشهور قوي اسمه ايه الله كشاني
اه مزبوط فعملوا ثوره على على الشاه
وعملوا اعتراض كبير جدا جدا وطلبوه بان هو
بيلغي هذا الاعتراف الشاه كان في الوقت ده
لسه شاب صغير لسه ماسك السلطه من تسع سنين
تقريبا او بعد والده فت راجع عن عن الموقف
ده لما موقفه قوي شويه سنه 60 اعترف بال
بعد ما تخلصوا من محمد مصدق و تاثير كشاني
ال وما الى ذلك ففوجئ الشاه ان في بقى شخص
شاب كده او شخص ايه الله اسمه ايه الله
الخميني الموساوي الخميني عرض الموضوع
وعمل بقى عارض العلاقه بين ايران واسرائيل
اه كان سبب العداء ما بين الشاه والخميني
اصلا مساله اعتراف الشاه وعلاقته باسرائيل
وطبعا انت عارف بقى الخميني كان ليه
علاقات بال بالنظام المصري في عهد عبد
الناصر ليه موضوع كبير جدا ف مساله اعتراف
الشه با اسرائيل كانت هي الاساس اللي خلى
خميني عفوا الخميني اللي هو مؤسس النظام
ده واللي هو قاضي الثوره ضد الشاه سنه 79
اه بد بقى من من 64 الى
79 شبه ثوره مستمره عظيم وعليه فانت بتقول
انه القضيه الفلسطينيه يعني من القضايا
المهمه في السياسه الخارجيه لا اسباب منها
انه مؤسس الجمهوريه الاسلاميه اللي هو
الامام الخميني كانت دي بالنسبه له خط
احمر ا العداء لاسرائيل هو احد الثوابت
المركزيه اللي قام عليها النظام الايراني
اللي بيحكم حتى الان وانت بتفصل بين هذا
وبين ان موجود قوى ايرانيه اخرى تعارض هذا
الخط مضبوط عظيم جدا نبدا بقى بالصحف
علشان الحديث ممتع وفي نفس الوقت احنا
عاوزين نقول للناس الصحف بتقول ايه والناس
في فيما يتعلق بالمستجدات ايه اكثر ما لفت
نظرك من الصحف الايرانيه في خلال الشهر
الماضي ولا انت تقول لنا خلال الاسبوع
الماضي انا هقول خلال الايام الماضيه في
ايران بنقسم الصحف لنوعين اه صحف اصلاحيه
وصحف معارضه الصحف الاصلاحيه عندها مساحه
اوسع ما في بعض في التحليلات هل ممكن
تديني اجابه موجزه جدا لما بتقول تيار
اصلاحي وتيار محافظ بس في ايجاز الفرق بين
التيار الاصلاحي والتيار المحافظ التيار
المحافظ في ايران باختصار هو التيار
الاكثر تشددا للثوابت الدينيه او الرافع
الديني في النظام اللي هو بيدافع عن ضروره
ان الدين يلعب الدين ورجال الدين يلعبوا
دور اكبر اه النظام الايراني واقف كده على
عكازين واحد منهم ديني واحد قومي
برجماتية عندهم برض الدين وكل حاجه ما
اختلفناش ومعمم وكل حاجه لكن الجانب
السياسي يعلو نوعا ما سنه بسيطه عن الجانب
الدين ده ده اختصار هو طبعا ممكن يكون مخل
لكن
ده ده عشان افهم الناس يعني ايه اصلاحي
ويعني ايه محافظ محافظ يعني متمسك بكل
المبادئ الدينيه اللي اللي قام عليها
النظام الايراني في الدستور ولها اصلا
مواد في الدستور معقده الاصلاحي بقى
يقوللك مش مشكله طيب ايه تنازل عن ده شويه
عشان اعتبارات سياسيه عظيم جدا طيب هنبدا
بالصحف الاصلاحيه نبدا بال الاصلاحيه ولا
الصحف اتفضل اه الاصلاحيه عندها مساحه
اكبر نوعا ما من ا بعض ايه الانتقاد
لمسؤولين الداخليين مسؤول هنا محافظ هنا
وزير هنا لهم لهم مساحه اوسع نسبيا على
اعتبار ان اللي بيحكم هم المحافظين هم
لحاب اليد العليا يعني مظبوط لان حاليا
اصلا الدوله الايرانيه بيحكمها بالكامل
المحافظين ندا بصحيفه صحيفه مشهوره قوي
عندهم اسمها ارمان ملي ارمان ملي يعني
ارمان ملي ارمان ملي ماشي تمام انا طبعا
انا بنطق حاجات بالنطق العربي لان نطق
بالنطق الفارسي هيختلف عن الكتاب امام
الليي يعني الامال الوطنيه ترجمتها كده
يعني معنى الكلام طبعا دي صحيفه اصلاحيه
مشهوره ومؤثره لان اللي بيكتب فيها
مسؤولين سابقين في الحكومه محللين مشاهير
وما الى ذلك
ا الصحيفه ركزت على ايه بقى على الزياره
اللي قام بها رئيس الوزراء
العراقي شياع السوداني لايران ولقاءه بعلي
خامنائي ده كان يوم ايه تذكر يا ده امبارح
امبارح مباشره امبارح اللي هو ت اكت اللي
هو ت اللي هو 6 نوفمبر اللي هو 6 نوفمبر 6
نوفمبر لكن لفتت بقى لنقطه في التحليل
بتاعها نقطه مهمه جدا بيقولوا ان الزياره
دي اولا الصحف الاصلاحيه تقول لك ايه ده
كان زياره مر عفوا الصحف المحافظه تقول لك
ده كان زياره مرتب ليها اصلا فال التوقيت
ليس له د اه لا الاصلاح يقوللك لا ما كانش
مرتب ليها دي جت بعد زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بلينكن للعراق وبالتالي رئيس
الوزراء العراقي هو محمل برساله للنظام
الايراني معناها ان ايران ان امريكا بتقول
لايران عن طريق العراق لو سمحتوا ما
تصعدوا لان احنا هنصعد ليه لان في الايام
اللي قبلها كان كل المسؤولين الايرانيين
يقول لك ايه الاصابع على على الزناد
والوضع سوف ينفجر ولو لم تكف اسرائيل عن
ضرب غزه احنا ماضمنش نفسنا وما نضمن الناس
اللي معانا
فالرسالة
اسرائيل كان في تقارير حتى قريتها انا عن
ان اسرائيل اعلنت وقف اطلاق النار لمده
يومين كلام من هذا القبيل تعتزم او تعتزم
كان في تقرير عن عن كلام من هذا القب ف
اتخلي المساعدات بوتيره اسرع كل هذه
الامور طبعا كان رساله وطبعا اللي بتقوله
ده يعني طبعا ده استنتاج من الصحيفه يعني
يعني هذا راي الصحيفه عشان نضع الامور
فييه نصابها ده يعني الافتتاحيه الصحيفه
نشرتها بترى فيها هذا الجانب من زياره
الرجل طبعا هو اصلا اي رئيس وزراء عراقي
هو بالنسبه لايران الحليف رقم واحد اساسا
والعمليات الايرانيه عن او عفوا العمليات
اللي بتقوم بها الجماعات التابعه لايران
في العراق اشتدت جدا ضد القوات الامريكيه
في الانبار في عين الاسد في حرير في اربيل
اكتر من مره في الايام اللي فاتت فهي كانت
رساله امريكيه طبعا للا خلافه في ذلك وانا
متفق مع التحليل ده عظيم
جدا التحليل الثاني او
الصحيفه الثانيه صحيفه اعتماد ودي صحيفه
برض من الصحف الاصلاحيه المهمه جدا هي
معناها باللغه العربيه الثقه اعتماد يعني
الثقه واعتمد عندنا معناها كده اه صحيفه
مهمه جدا ليه لان اللي بينشروا فيها
مؤثرين جدا في القطاعات الشبابيه وال
التليفن وعلى السوشيال ميديا مشهورين جدا
وفي تليجرام عندهم قنوات وما الى ذلك حتى
جواد ظريف نفسه كان بيكتب في هذه الصحيفه
في اكتر منز الخارجيه الايران السابق ففي
شخصيات وازنه بتكتب فيز الصحف دلوقتي ك
ظريف هو موجود في ايران يعني بيعمل ايه
يعني موجود عمل اكتر من ندوه او حلقه
نقاشيه في الاسابيع اللي فاتت عن غزه
واسرائيل وصراع مع اسرايل لكن لا يحتل اي
مواقع و لا لا لا يحتل اي شيء لا يحتل شيء
في تقارير او في تسريبات بتقول ان هو من
المفترض ان هو بيؤه يبقى رئيس جمهوريه في
الدوره الجايه طبعا ده انا ببعد ده لان هو
نفسه نفاه وقال انا عمري ما هعمل كده بس
مش
موضوعنا في
الصحيفه اعتماد في كاتب بقى كاتب مشهور
قوي اسمه محمد را
الكاتب ده عمل مفارقه ومقاره رائعه من
وجهه نظري ما بين الازمات الدوليه الراهنه
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه وخلاصتها اه بيقارن
ما بين الحربين دول والحرب اللي خضتها
ايران ضد العراق في ممان سنين من
1980 ل 88 بيقول فيها ان عنوان المقاله
ايه بقى من السهل ان تبدا الحرب لكن من
الصعب ان تنهيها
بدايه الحرب هو بيقول ان في اربع عوامل
بتخلي الجيش يبدا حرب
اولا المفاجا والمباغتة
اخر وده برض في ايران مش موجود لان ايران
ما عندهاش وفقا ليه هو ما عندهاش يعني
معلومات كفايه عن الجيش ده الجيش ده مسلح
بشكل ايه قدراته السياسيه ايه في اتخاذ
القرار ايه ده مش
موجود الحاجه الثالثه
ا المقدره لا الحاجه الرابعه عفوا
والاخيره التنسيق مع الفاعلين الخارجيين
اه فهو بيقول ان الاربع عوامل دول غير
متوفرين وانا هشرح هو بيقول كده ليه اه
طبعا احنا قلنا الثلاث الحاجات حضتك قلتهم
دول خلاص عرفناهم ايه التنسيق مع الفاعلين
الخارجيين هل ايران تقدر تدخل حرب مع
اسرائيل دون التنسيق مع شركائها في العالم
وفي الاقليم الاجابه لا لسبب بسيط لو
ايران دخلت حرب مع اسرائيل امريكا هتعمل
ايه امريكا اصلا محركه الحملات الطائرات
ليه عشان رضع ايران حتى لوضع تخيلي مظبوط
فاذا لو ايران عملت حرب طبعا ده غير وارد
اصلا واقول ليه غير وارد امريكا هتدخل
فبالتالي الصين هتحب تساندها وروسيا لكن
الصين وروسيا مشغولين في قضايا تانيه
الصين مشغوله في قضايا بحر الصين الجنوبي
والاندوسبرم
في اوكرانيا فبالتالي الفاعلين الدوليين
مش هيساعدوك فما تقدرش تخش حرب هتقف فيها
منفرده مع الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها قدام النو اذا هو بيخلص انه بخلص
ان من الاخر بيقدم نصيحه للنظام الايراني
لكن بشكل لافف وغير مباشر ان الاربع عوام
دول اللي هم الاساسيين في اتخاذ قرار بدء
الحرب غير متوفرين عند ايران اصلا طب
استاذنك بس العنصر الثالث تقصد به تضخم
قوات الدوله المعاديه يعني زياده قوتها
تصور ضخامه او ضاله القوات التقدير يعني
تقديره انه الوقت مناسب ان انا اهجم عليه
لا لا تقديره لقوه الجيش الاخر او ضعفه
يعني ليه الناس ليه الناس بتحارب ليه ليه
صدام حسين بدا الحرب ضد ايران تصور ان في
وضع ضعيف الله ده اللي انا بقوله تقديره
الخاطئ ليه قوه ايران اذا العنصر الثالث
انه اذا انه يدخل الحرب اذا تصور انه
الطرف الاخر في وضع اضعف مظبوط عظيم جدا
فهو بيقول ان اسرائيل مش وضعه اضعف هو
بيقول ان اسرائيل وضعها قوي مسلحه ومدعوم
امريكيا النيتو كله كل المسؤولين الكبار
راحوا اسرائيل تاني يوم من عمليه افان
الاقصى فبالتالي احنا مش هنحارب اسرائيل
احنا هنحارب النيتو عظيم جدا عندنا ايه
صحف تانيه ا الاصلاحيه برض في بقى صحيفه
برض انا بميل قوي قي ان انا اخد حاجات
منها صحيفه افطا يزد اطاب يزد اطاب يعني
شمس اه باحدى الهجات او اللغات
الايرانيه يزد محافظه في ايران محافظه في
وسط ايران كده شمس شمس يزد شمس يزد ويزد
طبعا يزد دي مدينه تاريخيه ليها وضع يعني
ففي الصحيفه دي عملت حوار مع احد المحليين
المشهورين اللي بيكتب مع مين بقى اللي
بيكتب مع ارمان ملي اللي قلنا عليها في
الاول الراجل ده اسمه الدكتور عبد الرضا
فرج راد الراجل ده استاذ جغرافيا سياسيه
جامعي وله اراء مشهوره شخص وازن في ايران
ف بيتحدث
بشكل موسع كده عن ان النيتو الان تحليله
هو الشخصي بدا يضغط
على عفوا مش النيتو الدول الاوروبيه
الوزنه في النيتو بدات تضغط على امريكا
لاجبار اسرائيل على وقف اطلاق النار وهم
عندهم تقدير موقف ان الوضع مين هم اللي هم
الدول الثلاثه في النيتو اللي هم الدول
الاساسيين يعني اللي هو المانيا فرنسا
بريطانيا هم عندهم تقديم موقف ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا اضرت النيتو ويجب وقفها فورا
وبالتالي هذا الوضع ينسحب على غزه وان حرب
اسرائيل على غزه ادرت النيتو جدا جدا في
علاقاته مع الدول العربيه ويجب وقفها فورا
لا يعني وفتحت جبهه ثانيه وشتت الانتباه
عن الخطر الاساسي اللي جاينه من روسيا عبر
اوكرانيا مظبوط وحتى هو بيقول في التحليل
بتاعه ان حتى الاوروبيين راحوا وقالوا
لامريكا ا روسيا بعيد عنكم فانتم مش حاسين
بيها لكن انتم من ساعه ما حرب اسرائيل
بدات على غزه وانتوا وانتم سبتوا خلاص ملف
اوكرانيا وعمالين تدعموا اسرائيل وحتى
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه قالت احنا
محتاجين ان احنا نرجع تاني ندعم اوكرانيا
عشان ما ننشغل مع اسرائيل عن الملف بقى
الاساسي لان ده بقى ملف حدود بقى مش ملف
يعني امن قومي بالنسبه لاوروبا ببساطه
لانه اشتعال الصراع في الشرق الاوسط هيكون
خصما من اهتمام الولايات المتحده على
الاقل فضلا عن دول اخرى بمواجهه الروس في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه واوكرانيا هي الاهتمام
الاول مبو وانا هسر بقى بعض الحاجات اللي
هو قالها ده من عندي انا مش من عنده هو ان
مثلا كان اسرائيل ليها 1000 او 2000
مستشار عسكري مع زيلينسكي في اوكرانيا
سحبتهم اه عشان كده زيلينسكي بس فين بقى
المعلومه دي انا بسمع عنها هل مثلا هم
بيتكلموا عن كده لا المعلومه مشهوره لغ ان
زيلينسكي اصلا عرض ان هو يزور اسرائيل
واسرائيل رفضت اه رفضوا استقباله اكثر من
مره في الايام اللي فاتت لما كانوا
الرؤساء بيتفوا على تلبيب لكن مؤخرا بعد
بقى ما سحبوا مستشاريهم وقواتهم من
اوكرانيا ده اللي ضايق بريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا ان اسرائيل كانت تدعمنا واسرائيل
معانا في الحرب وجنودها ومستشارين مع
زيلينسكي فسحبت لما قامت الحرب بتاعه غزه
طب ما هو اذا زعل بريطانيا وفرنسا الاولى
انه يزعل زيلينسكي مظبوط فزل نسكي رايح
يستجدي اسرائيل طيب لا تع سعدون طبعا
اسرائيل سعدت اوكرانيا اصلا اداتها بعض
الاسلحه وقطع الغيار وما الى ذلك دي ده
كلام منشور الكلام مش عندي ف تحليلي انا
بكمل كلامه ان دي وجه نظر قد تكون صائبه
بالنسبه كبيره هي هي منطقيه جدا منطقيه
جدا ده صحيح يا ترى عندنا صحف ايه يحفظه
اه كده خلصنا صحف الاصلاحيه طبعا صحف
الاصلاحيه مش عايز اقولك بالعشرات
بالعشرات لكن دول ابرزهم واشهرهم في حوالي
10 صحف محافظه تثقيله ومؤثره ووزنه لكن
انا اخترت ثلاثه وفقا للتحليل المحتوى عن
غزه فيهم اول صحيفه هي صحيفه اسمها
الطلاءات اطلاقات بالعربي ننطقها اطلاعات
اه ا الصحيفه دي معناها بالعربي يعني ايه
يعني المعلومات دي اقدم صحيفه في ايران
صحيفه انشات سنه 1926 فليها مصداقيه ليها
ليها عراقه ليها وضع يعني ا الصحيفه دي
نشره مقاله في الصفحه الاولى لكاتبه
ونائبه سابقه في البرلمان اسمها جميله
كديفار اه ا وجميله كديفار هي شخصيه مؤثره
جدا شخصيه لها علاقات واسعه جدا زارت مصر
اكتر من مره وقابلت الاستاذ محمد حسنين
هيكل وليها كتاب منشور في دار الشروق
عندنا في مصر اسمه ايران بعيون مصريه عظيم
ا عفوا مصر بعيون ايرانيه وبتتكلم عن هذا
الموضوع وهي خبيره في في السياسه في الشرق
الاوسط وسافرت اكتر من دوله في المنطقه ف
كلامها مؤثر فبتقول ايه بقى بتقول ان في
اكذوبه روجت لها اسرائيل وهي ان اسرائيل
هي التي انشات ودعمت حماس نكايه في حركه
فتح لما كانت اسرائيل على خلاف مع حركه
فتح في عهد رئيس ابو عمار اللي هو ياسر
عرفات بتقول ان عمليه طوفان الاقصى واللي
حصل فيها من طبعا قتل اسرائيليين واسر
اسرائيليين بيطحط الروايه الاسرائيليه
التاريخيه اللي تم ترويجها في وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان حماس دول بتوعنا
ودي مصلحتنا ان هم اصلا يستولوا على
السلطه في غزه وما الى ذلك مقاله مهمه جدا
جدا فبناء عليه بتدافع نوعا ما عن عن حماس
وبتها جم اسرائيل اللي فضلت تخدع الراي
العام الداخلي في اسرائيل لسنوات طويله ان
حماس دي صنعتنا وان احنا اللي انشانا وما
ال ذلك انا عايز استاسم حضرتك ك نستغل
القصه ديت في استدراج بسيط لاصدقائي يعني
لانه النقطه دي انا فوجئت ان هي بتلقى
قبول اما عن غرد او عن يعني جهل وحتى
مجموعه من زملاء اولادي يعني في الجامعه
وجوم بيسالوني عن النقطه دي تحديدا استوضح
استاذنك في اقل من دقيقه اجذوبه انه حماس
صنيع اسرائيليه هي كلمه حق يراد بها باطل
او مش عارف تصوغها ازاي اسرائيل دعمت ح
حماس بهدف ان هي تسبح لها بالتواجد
والترخيص والوجود مش حبا في حماس ولا لان
حماس جمعه عميله ولكن لانه هي كانت ترغب
في محاربه فتح والضغط عليها في الانتخابات
والتواجد وتتاكد من وجود قوه لها اجنده
مختلفه مبوط وبالتالي لما يكون في قوتين
مش كلهم تحت فتح يبقى في نوع من الانقسام
ده كان الهدف ليس اكثر وليس اقل وده بيحصل
طول الوقت حماس كونها استفادت من مخطط
اسرائيل ده مش معناها ان هم يعني عملاءه
بينسوا دي جماعه مقاومه مستقله ومافيش
اسرائيلي بيقول دول عملاء لينا ولكن هم
معتقدين ان وجودهم يصب في مصلحه اسرائيل
لانه هيبقي على القضيه الفلسطينيه مقسمه
بين معسكرين مبو ده كلام كلام مظبوط تماما
و ده ف عن اللي بيتقال وهي هنا بتحاول
يعني تفند النظريه دي الصحيفه الخامسه
معانا او الصحيفه الثانيه في الصحف
المحافظه صحيفه كيهان صحيفه كيهان دي لو
احنا نطقناها بالعربي هنقول كيهان بس هي
اسمها كيهان بالفارسي كيهان يعني ايه يعني
العالم كويس عشان
كده دي صحيفه من اهم الصحف الحاليه
الصحيفه تقريبا الاولى بالنسبه للمرشد
الايراني رئيس تحريرها اسمه حسين
شريعتمداري ده من اكتر الصحفيين المقربين
جدا من المرشد
الايراني كلامه مشهور ومؤثر ووازن وبنفض
نحلل من كلامه وجهات النظام هذا الرجل كان
في مؤتمر اسمه مؤتمر او ندوه
لافتتاح اذاعه المقاومه ده كان يوم 5
نوفمبر يعني اول امبارح بيقول فيه بكل
بساطه ان امريكا هتخسر لانها ربطت نفسها
بذيل حصان خاسر هو الحصان الاسرائيلي
والحصان الكاسب دائما هو اصحاب الارض
هو الفلسطينيين وبتن فيها بزوال اسرائيل
وبنهايه اسرائيل و بيقول ان هذه الحرب
بدايه نهايه دوله الكيان اصلا ف اللي
بيحصل الحرب دي توريط لامريكا تشويه لسمعه
امريكا اللي هي اصلا مشوهه بس يعني تشويه
جامد جدا جدا لسمعه امريكا في العالم
اهانه للسلاح الامريكي اللي مع مع اسرائيل
ما هو التكنولوجيه السلاح اللي مع اسرائيل
ايه
تكنولوجيا امريكيه غربيه مظبوط السلاح
اللي مع حماس تكنولوجيه ايه ايرانيه روسيه
كوريه شماليه فلما يطلع شاب كده عنده 20
سنه من حماس
بصاروخ كورنت قد كده يضرب الدبابه اللي هي
مرك اللي مكلفه 20 مليون دولار في لحظه
فهو هنا بيهد الصوره الذهنيه بتاع سمعه
السلاح الامريكيه في سوق السلاح العالمي
ده صحيح فبالتالي اسرائيل ادرت امريكا ضج
جامد جدا من خلال هذه الح على مستويات
المتعدده الحقيقه يعني في مراكز الفكر
طبعا مراكز الفكر في ايران اكثر من ان
تحصى لكن في مركز نشط جدا بقاله كم سنه
كده اسمه مركز ابرار المركز النشط جدا
وبينشر حاجات مقتضبه سريعه ومكثفه لكن
فيها يعني خلاصه وزبده ايران عايزه تقول
ايه في القضيه الفلانيه فا ابرار نشرت
مقاله لباحث اسمه حسين اجرول ده باحث برض
باحث وازن وباحث محترم هناك بيقول ايه بقى
بيقول ان عمليه طوفان الاقصى وما استتبع
من عمليه اسرائيليه اللي هي السيوف
الحديديه هي دليل على افول سمعه اسرا
اسرائيل في الصحه الدوليه طب سمعه اسرائيل
دي ازاي قفلت هو بيقول
بيستنجد بتقارير منظمه الصحه العالميه
منظمه الغذاء العالميه منظمه الادويه
العالميه وما الى ذلك ثم الموقف الشهير
بقى بتاع امين عام الامم المتحده اللي
انتقد في اسرائيل وما الى ذلك فهو كان
بيقول ان الروايه الاسرائيليه التي تم
ترويجها من سنه 48 حتى الان المظلوميه وان
هم تعرضوا الهولوكوست في اوروبا وهم دوله
مش معتد ودوله مسلمى والاخر هو اللي
بيعتدي عليهم لكن لما كل هذه المنظمات
الدوليه المحايده او حتى هي اللي المفروض
اصلا طبعه للغرب تنتقد اسرائيل كل هذا
الانتقاد فهي ب ايه بتفن القصه كلها من
اولها لاخرها قصه اسرائيل وقصه انشاء
اسرائيل وقصه الهولوكوست واصبح ان اسرائيل
هي اللي بتقوم بالهولوكوست وان هي فعلا
سمعتها في الانظمه والمحافل الدوليه اصبحت
ا في الحديد وده بيبش وبينزل من وجه نظر
نظره وده اللي بيتفق بقى مع امين مع اللي
قاله حسين شرع المداري في كيهان فلما نفهم
ان اكتر من شخص وازن ومهم في اكثر من وصيه
اعلام ومركز ابحاث بيقول
كلام بشكل ما واحد لكن بطرق مختلفه نفهم
ان الدوله الايرانيه عايزه تقول لاسرائيل
ان اللي بتعمليه في غزه هو بدايه نهايه
هذه الدوله ربنا يخليك معالي الدكتور كانت
جوله ثريه قدرنا نعرف فيها الكثير مما
يفكر فيه الايرانيون والنخب الايرانيه بغض
النظر تتفق مع ما قالته هذه النخب او
تختلفوا تحبونه لا تحبونه احنا مش هدفنا
ان انتم لا تحبوه ولا تكرهوه هدفنا ان
انتم تعرفوه واتمنى ان يكون هذا الهدف قد
تحقق وان شاء الله مع مزيد من اخبار ايران
نبقى معانا حلقات حلقات اخرى اذا سمح وقت
الدكتور ان شاء الله معال الدكتور ان شاء
الله يا فندم انا يسعدني جدا التقي بحضرتك
وب جمهور القناه جمهور واعي ومحترم ويه
شرف يعني ربنا يخليك ويسعدك شكرا لك وشكرا
لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى باذن الله